il m'a fait tirer sur lui
n'arrêtait pas de dire que je n'étais pas réel c'était presque
comme si tu étais une personne différente tu as
raison il peut parfois devenir plus
ferme ta perruque qu'est-ce que je fais ici
tu ne te souviens pas que l'armée noire s'est retournée contre
nous
Je pense que je suis la deuxième étape n'a jamais
annulé l'architecte de la société beaucoup de
travail à faire Je peux arrêter ça non vous tirez sur
le cordon maintenant ils auront gagné Des
catastrophes mondiales comme celle-ci se produisent
parce que je suis comme si quelque chose se
passait ça pourrait  soyez grand cela
va marquer la fin d'une Corp c'est votre
moment vous ne pouvez pas vous détourner maintenant si vous
tirez les bonnes ficelles une marionnette
dansera comme vous le désirez l'armée noire a
besoin de savoir ce qu'il a fait vous
comprenez les conséquences elle est un
terroriste
si vous ne faites rien ils ne
reviendront pas de ça